the lands between it's an interesting
name for the world we play the game in
right the lands between what exactly
the opening cinematic refers to the
lands between as our home across the fog
in the lands between
the great elden ring
was shattered
in our home
across the fog
the lands between
the narrator for this first cinematic
talks about what came of the demigods
after the shattering of the elden ring
and screams out to us the tarnished to
return to our home across the fog and
mend a fractured elden ring for an outer
god known as the greater will who gives
us our sight of grace this grace shows
us the path required to mend the elden
ring because to the greater will that's
all we're good for right to fix what was
broken but it was broken by its own
chosen imperian which brings up in my
opinion the biggest question that we can
have answered why would queen america
batter the elden ring was she trying to
stop her children from battling each
other for more power was she trying to
make the greater will stronger through
death and struggle which feeds the
greater will or did she simply have
enough of what was and needed something
to change maybe queen america the
eternal
has been with the greater will for far
longer than we think and in many
different places the story of elden ring
to many of us is a complicated
interwoven confusing sequence of events
through a timeline that seems to have a
mind of its own but what if there was a
reason
why it feels this way what if the lands
between are literally between worlds
dimensions or timelines that have folded
into one another and have created the
fractured world that we play in instead
of seeing the guidance of grace as the
only true path it can also be seen as a
parasite disease or virus that has come
to this world destroyed and hidden away
what came before it infected the minds
and wills of those who are there now and
constantly fights against a change for
the future many of those who once
followed the greater will are now
fighting against it as they realize that
there was a world that came before it
and a future is possible without it when
the golden order's influence fades from
the eyes of those that once saw its
grace their eyes don't just fade but
their belief fades with it i believe
this is why the elden ring was shattered
so much converged onto this land that
queen merica's eyes were once again
opened to the possibilities of what came
before and what can come after this
theory i believe is an important start
to thinking outside the box of what we
may know to be true within elden ring's
lore and may have many more similarities
to dark souls lore than we may have
first realized however it's really
important to note that this theory is
exactly that an outside the box theory
based on a lot of speculation so try to
keep an open mind and discuss calmly
about what you think down in the
comments
before we continue i'd like to talk
about our sponsor for today's video
nordvpn eldon ring's world may be
terrifying and complicated but the real
world can be just as bad if not worse
especially over the internet if you're
like me much of my life and work is
online so it's important to have access
to anything i may need from anywhere in
the world and feel safe when doing so if
you have a game that isn't available or
may have a discount in a different
region nordvpn allows you to change your
virtual location to servers in 59
different countries with over 5600
servers available nord does this
securely to help you avoid ddos attacks
block malware ridden websites secure
your browser without affecting your
latency and uses next generation
encryption to keep you as safe as
possible my mind is already filled with
complicated theories on all things elden
ring so using a vpn is just one of those
nice things to help keep my mind at ease
and with nord's new threat protection
vpn that protects you from malicious
websites malware trackers and intrusive
ads nordvpn is just the best choice that
i couldn't recommend more if you go to
the link on screen or in the description
you can get a two-year plan with a huge
discount plus one month free and a
30-day money-back guarantee go check out
nordvpn so you can feel safe secure and
worry-free thank you nordvpn for
sponsoring this video
this entire game is based around one
character and her plan to destroy what
controls her queen america the eternal
she is the center of everything the
vassal of what apparently gives life an
order to all in the lands between the
elden ring but how long has queen
america been with the greater will is
the lands between the only world the
golden order has influenced what
actually is the lands between this world
that we play the game in in my opinion
feels almost like a fever dream it's
just bizarre right like the feeling of
none of what is here is actually meant
to be here the best way i can describe
it is as it's like the world is folding
in on each other and it's fracturing
itself fragments of everything are
everywhere spread around randomly with
nothing actually guiding anything and
this is a very strange feeling to have
in a world that has a towering golden
tree that is meant to represent order
but the world we are brought back into
as a tarnished is a fractured one we are
just witnesses to the aftermath of
everything that has happened we are told
that the guiding light of grace will
lead us to our true destiny to mend the
elden ring and become elden lord that's
already an enticing reason to just
follow the light but why are we the only
ones who can see the guiding light not
even melano can see this light and she's
meant to help us through our entire
journey this tiny golden aura is the
grace of the earth tree this light
once shone in the eyes of your tarnished
brethren
but now
it is all that guides you
also i hear
you can see them can't you
the rays of grace
that guide you through your burden
devout followers like corrin are excited
to tell us that it's a major rarity to
see the guidance of grace
you do
wonderful news
most tarnished are blind to it these
days
you are something of a rare breed we
seem to be one of the last remaining
beings in the lands between that are
still influenced by the greater will in
this way but what does it mean to follow
grace at the beginning for us it's what
drives us toward greatness becoming the
most powerful and influential being in
all of the lands between becoming elden
lord sounds like the only possible goal
for us but as we venture through the
world we are shown and told what the
golden order truly is a parasite from
another world entirely and has for
generations infected the minds of
everybody and seeks to destroy all who
came before it and all who stands
against it queen america has been
witness to all of it and has likely
never had true control of her actions
her fingers do the bidding of the
greater will as she houses the very
thing that controls her within herself
the shattering of the elden ring was her
plan to finally be free from this
parasite and she set many things into
motion to not only free herself but make
sure the greater will can't get back
into full control each ending that we
may choose as a tarnish goes according
to america's plan to either destroy
replace or at least weaken the greater
will ronnie's ending is the most obvious
the new age of the stars
now cometh the age of the stars
a thousand-year voyage under the wisdom
of the moon
[Music]
here making it the chill night that
encompasses all
reaching the great beyond
there have been many different
interpretations of ronnie's ending what
i believe she's referring to here is to
actually leave the lands between on a
literal voyage to another world entirely
this moon that we can see forming during
her ending is a teleporter or a sending
gate to completely leave the greater
will behind we'll have to discuss this
fully in a separate video but eldon ring
has many different ways of
transportation throughout the game
there's the sights of grace that we can
transport freely between the sending
gate teleporters like at the four
belfries and in randomly placed areas
crap chess teleporters coffins with
cipher runes that have something to do
with gravity magic dream transportation
with order sacks inside of godwin and
the ancestral spirits time travel when
entering the dragonlord fight even
melana is seemingly teleporting us to
pharah missoula after her sacrifice to
the forge of the giants i believe this
is why we can find alexander stuck in
holes that are the exact size of him
he's falling from the sky after an
unsuccessful teleportation the theory on
this is that teleportation through all
of these means is meant for just the
tarnished or those who still have the
sight of grace and as we know alexander
takes the flesh of fallen warriors to
fill his jar and many of those who
likely once had the sight of grace he's
attempting teleportation and because he
only has the flesh of those with grace
randomly within him doesn't go well
every time he attempts it alexander can
be summoned during our fight with the
fire giant and it isn't too far of a
stretch to say that he may have used the
forge of the giants to teleport to
pharaoh azula with us or soon after us
another example of teleportation or
transmissions can be seen with the two
fingers in the round table hold at a
certain point in the game the fingers
are pointing straight up sort of like an
antenna in an attempt to communicate
telepathically with the greater will
the fingers
remain still
shaken
by this turn of events they are busy
consulting the crystal will
when they are finished
the fingers will again offer their
guidance
but thousands
if not tens of thousands
of moons must first pass
no matter for me
but you
how will you ever manage to wait
my
oh my
we could go so much deeper with this but
let's save that for another video
ronnie's ending is basically us leaving
the lands between and the greater will
behind using this
portal the dung eater's ending can be
seen as a replacement of the golden
order and a return to what came before
the greater will everyone will be cursed
everyone will be an omen but it can
still be seen as a replacement which
works with america's plan the dung eater
was given grace but maybe this was on
purpose by queen america to enact the
dung eater's will if that plan ends up
in his favor it's not a happy ending but
it is an ending to the golden order
nonetheless even the gold mass ending
doesn't exactly end up in the favor of
the greater will the quest line is all
about the realization that the golden
order is not as strong or as holy as one
may have thought i finally come to
understand
the master was nothing more than a
madman
enchanted by a vain and ruinous delusion
he rejected the perfection of the golden
order
seeking to supplant our glorious faith
with his own
[Laughter]
could there be
a more pitiable comedy
look at it
the culmination of perfection
burning
before our very eyes
[Laughter]
this means that even though the golden
order still stands with this ending the
people who once devoted themselves fully
to it are now questioning the legitimacy
of itself called perfection the flame of
frenzy ending is just the pure
destruction of the greater will entirely
burning everything and everyone
completely however merica didn't want
the flame of frenzy and offshoot three
fingers of the greater will to take full
control either so she manifested a
fragment of herself melana to help the
tarnished on her journey warn us to
leave the flame of frenzy alone and if
we did choose this path of chaos he
would stop at nothing to take us down
the age of fracture ending or the one
where we just mend the elden ring is us
becoming elden lord in keeping the world
almost exactly as it is fractured so
while the greater will still remains it
will almost never become fully mended
finally there's fia in godwin's ending
the age of the dustborn this is where
death will be known in the lands between
for the first time in many ages of the
greater will and this obviously goes
against what the golden order would want
this works in favor of america's plan
that not only goes against the greater
will's wishes but also sets in motion
godwin or the prince of death and his
continued infection of the roots of the
earth tree earlier in the video i
referred to the greater will as a
disease or a virus how do you get rid of
or kill a virus well in our real world
vaccines are created from the causative
agent of a disease and are treated to
act as an antigen and provide immunity
against the disease godwin was a devout
follower of the golden order and his
soul was killed in the night of black
knives not only to assist ronnie in the
killing of her empyrean flesh but to
also have godwin's body used as a sort
of vaccine to slowly take over the
greater wills influence of the urgery
representations of real world things are
all over this game the golden order can
be seen as a disease virus fungus or
tumor that is now slowly being taken
over by godwin's body as a sort of
treatment or vaccine the formless mother
or the god of blood that moog follows
can also be represented as a disease of
the blood that could become inflamed
obviously the god of rot can be seen as
an infection and the ancestral spirits
represent life after death all of this
needs to go into its own video to
explain thoroughly so be on the lookout
for that along with the teleportation
features that we discussed earlier the
point of all of this is that each and
every action seems to be correlated to
that of america's plan to destroy that
which has controlled her for so long
america originated from the newman race
who resided in the underground cities of
nochron and noxtella it's theorized that
they traveled to the lands between from
an entirely different world the
description of the newman race in the
character select screen reads the face
of the newman supposed descendants of
denzians of another world long lived but
seldom born america's hammer description
tells us that the hammer was made in the
lands of the newman outside the lands
between so nothing tells us exactly that
the newmans are outside the planet of
the lands between entirely but there is
a lot that suggests that queen america
has been the vassal of the elden ring
and the greater will for who knows how
long when we take a closer look at the
boss arena during the fight against the
elden beast we can see many different
trunks of the urgery i believe that this
suggests that what we're attempting to
defeat here is a manifestation of the
greater will in each in every dimension
think about it we all have our own
journeys throughout the lands between
each of us are tarnished past with the
same thing to mend the elden ring and
become elden lord but each and every one
of us are going to make different
choices all of us are going to take
vastly different paths and depending on
who we meet who we choose to follow who
we choose to help or kill we will be
presented with different endings of our
own unique journeys in other words our
world is our own and other worlds exist
every player who plays this game all
along the same spectrum and all starting
with a tarnished who seeks the door to a
tree but to truly destroy the greater
will it must be affected in some way in
each in every one of those scenarios
through each and every one of those
dimensions america is aware of this
since she is the vassal for the very
thing she seeks to destroy she knows all
and has set everything into place to
make sure that no matter what we choose
as a tarnished that a change will be
made in the lands between a change is
all she wants even if it means she
remains mended to the elden ring ronnie
understands america's plan which is why
i believe her ending is the one that
brings about the most change and is what
america truly wanted ronnie says it best
when we talk to her in her miniature
doll form deep in the heart of noxtella
where america is originally from
let us speak of the past a while
i was once an imperial
of the demigods
only i
michela and melania could claim that
title
each of us was chosen by our own two
fingers
as a candidate to succeed queen marika
to become the new god of the coming age
but i would not acquiesce to the two
fingers
i stole the rune of death
slew mine own imperial flesh
casting it away
i would not be controlled by that thing
thank you all for watching i'd like to
give a special thanks to retro who
helped me a ton by discussing and
developing this theory with me he said
he's gonna start streaming on twitch
soon so go show him some love there you
should also join our discord where he
and i actually started this discussion
and funny enough that discussion started
with alexander and actually led to all
of this which i think is awesome looking
at eldon ring from a different
perspective has really opened up my
inspiration for making these videos
again of course let me know what you all
think in the comments there's going to
be holes in the story so join the
discord follow me on twitter whatever
you want to do and let's figure all of
this out together thank you to all the
patrons who got to see this video early
with no ads along with some other
special exclusives during production of
the video expect more videos like this
very soon and i will see you all in the
next one take care